thì nó cách nhau bún mẹ
đúng không?
ở đây là ở bên nhau bún mẹ
thì như thế
rất là dí chuyển xuống tần hầm xong năm mẹ
rất là mấy cho đi
xuống tần hầm này
nó xong năm mẹ
đúng là
thì khoảng cái này bún năm mẹ này
có sao
xong đó đi lưng tần mà
đúng không
tần mà để không biết là ngoan nhiều mở thật gì ở đây ăn đây ở tần mà này
gì là dưới tần mà không có tần 2
đúng không?
nhưng mà mình trong cái trong cái miền nà mẹ
đúng ing mình lên ngư hơi khó chiitute ổ tỉ
từng t unemploy
có thật content
Neither lòng có cleaned l recreate
l meva lên không
là là nó đã nói là
xuất là l candles 2 đâu
xuất là lời lòng m 차 elle backgrounds
lòng 2
khoảng JA
khi mà các bạn vẽ
bất title không buatley
đây làicks hômTre mà
cannot d Dance
Nếu chờ, cui nào thì nó sẽ quan tâm đến gì các bạn
A quan lưu thì nó sẽ quan tâm đến điểm đầu được cuối
Đúng không?
Nào tịt là nó cũng sảo, nó có thể nụ bị chuyển luôn
Đúng bị chuyển nó sẽ quan tâm đến điểm đầu được cuối nước ngoài
Điểm đầu là tâm sẽ tâm là ít bằng không
Điểm cuối là lâu xuất mà là ít bằng ngoài hai
Thì nên chỉ cần quan tâm là thì nhờ
Tó đồ, ít bà tức là của lâu qua, chứ tò đồ của tâm sẽ đi ở sọc
Đúng không?
Để mấy hai chiếc không?
Vào mấy hai, vậy?
Để xin là cách chúng ta sẽ đi quán lượng đúng không?
Đã khi người này lên lâu qua
À khoảng lúc truyển để nhờ
Quán lưu thì mình quan tâm đến cuối á, thì nó sẽ đi gì nào
Con lâu lúc truyển, nó sẽ đi điểm đầu được cuối rồi
Thần lâu kinh của thấy thành định dẫn thêm các bạn nhìn vào bài dàng hành nế